Bonjour. Vous voulez apprendre à séduire des filles et à pécho un maximum en soirée ? Cette vidéo est faite pour vous
Tout d'abord, commencez par vous abonner à la chaîne de Squeezie
Ceci n'est pas une arnaque
Les amis, j'ai reçu un mail qui a attiré mon attention.
C'est Josh séduction qui m'a informé de ses créations. Il a créé deux applications qui s'appellent "Coach Seduction" et "Envoyer des sms de séduction"
qui sont des applications
probablement destinées à des gens un peu plus vieux que nous ok, à des gens qui ont 60 ans et non pas 20 mais d'après
ses dires, à la fin de cette vidéo nous serons capables de séduire des femmes en toutes
circonstances, de manière efficace et de manière sûre, plus jamais vous vous retrouverez dans un moment de gêne face à une femme, ça n'arrivera plus.
Je suis sur l'application, ça va se passer en trois étapes :  dans "Conseille moi", tu retrouveras tous les conseils officiels écrit par nous ;
Dans "Motive moi", je serais là pour t'apporter de l'énergie au moment où tu en auras besoin;
Dans "Évalue moi", je pourrais voir si ton niveau théorique est suffisant avant de te lancer dans la pratique.
Première étape : "Conseille moi". Apprends-moi, je veux savoir séduire ! Il peut te conseiller pour séduire en journée, en soirée,
pour séduire un mec, pour séduire par messages, pour séduire sur internet, en rendez-vous ou en couple. Quoi ?! C'est pas cool du tout ça, c'est scandaleux.
Ok en journée. Les bases. Mais mec, c'est hyper complet, c'est génial
Le lieu : "tu peux aborder dans la rue, dans un magasin, dans un parc, un jardin public, un centre commercial, à la plage ... " Mais c'est
du harcèlement de rue ça apparemment d'après certaines femmes
faut faire attention. Attention, elles n'ont pas forcément envie d'être dérangées dans la rue. Deux cas difficiles : si la fille est avec un groupe d'amis ; ils ont
analysé des femmes c'est glauque, "ou si elle est dans un endroit dit à
"pression sociale", par exemple dans le bus" ; Effectivement on n'est pas l'abri d'une petite descente du coude dans les boules hein bon. Autres conseils de
bon sens mais ça ne fait pas de mal de le rappeler ; j'adore comment il parle
"évite les rues sombres et étroites la nuit la fille aura tendance à prendre peur plus facilement"
J'espère que parmi vous personne n'a tenté de séduire une fille dans une rue étroite et sombre la nuit, vraiment. "Ne te mets pas trop
de barrières en soit tous les lieux sont possibles" avec
une faute d'orthographe. L''état d'esprit:
Attention, est-ce que t'a le mind (*esprit) ? Si t'a pas le mind la fille va le sentir hein
c'est comme les chevaux si t'es stressé, ils le sentent.Et je viens de comparer les femmes aux chevaux. Allez à bientôt, fin de carrière. "Soit de bonne
humeur c'est contagieux la personne à qui tu parles le sera aussi. Ne te prends pas trop au sérieux
amuse-toi de chaque situation. " Mec, je suis désolé de te dire bière, faut faire attention quand même.
"Hé ! Coucou Mélanie, tu vas bien ?" - ça va, ça va "Alors, tu racontes quoi
aujourd'hui là ? C'est la fête, il fait beau, on est bien. On est au taquet, hein, on est au taquet" - Ma mère vient de mourir
"Soit de bonne humeur c'est contagieux la personne à qui tu parles le sera aussi. Ne te prends pas trop au sérieux amuse-toi de chaque situation. "
"Oh merde ! Oh putain, sa mère est morte !
Elle est tombée dans les marches ? Elle est tombée dans la marches ? Oh c'est énorme ! C'est énorme !
"Reste humble, même si tu possèdes des biens matériels, n'essaie pas de le montrer à tout prix. Par exemple, si tu as un yacht, mentionne simplement un petit bateau ainsi tu gagnes l'effet de
surprise mais en plus tu as l'air de quelqu'un d'humble." T'as l'air d'un gros fils de pute, ouais. Bon, j'ai pas réussi à trouver mieux mais bon ça
va quoi. Non ! "De plus, tes réactions et tes émotions (ne pas rire aux éclats pour quelque chose de moyennement marrant, ne pas être excessivement
triste pour quelque chose de banal)."Ne sois pas Squeezie. Ok ? On passe à l'énergie
"Avant de commencer, si tu n'es pas au top de ton énergie, utilise les méthodes ci-dessous : remémore toi les meilleurs moments vécus dans ta vie
Quand je suis passé diamant sur Overwatch. "Exerce-toi, notamment en saluant des inconnus en souriant. "
"Si tu es un peu endormi, cours quelques instants (de 30 secondes à une minute), cela te réveillera" Tu vas surtout puer en arrivant
à ton rendez-vous. Mon gars fait pas ça
Passons au langage du corps
"Un homme confiant n'hésite pas à prendre de la place". Manspreading, arrêtez ! "Quand tu expliques quelque chose, utilise des mouvements" La dernière fois,
le mec il arrive là, j'lui fais "Mec!" Pardon
Ne faites aucun geste brusque vous pourriez blesser la femme, vraiment. "Apprends à être à l'aise avec tes mains". Est-ce qu'un jour quelqu'un vous a
dit "J'ai un problème dans la vie, je suis mal à l'aise avec mes mains". S'il ya bien quelque chose avec lequel tu n'est pas
mal à l'aise, c'est ta main. Surtout quand tu te fais une bonne grosse partie de ping pong
Merci à tous
Les amis, il est temps d'apprendre à gérer le contact visuel
"Dès l'instant où tu te trouves en face de votre interlocuteur, regarde son visage et surtout pas sa poitrine !"
Soutiens son regard. Si tu n'y arrives pas tu peux regarder autour de ses yeux, le plus proche possible de ses pupilles."
C'est dérangeant, c'est dérangeant, ne le faites pas
"Tu peux, par exemple, utiliser la technique des trois zones : regarde l'oeil droit, le gauche, la bouche, le décolleté" Non ! Tous ces conseils me mettent
profondément mal à l'aise. Tous. "Acquiesce en faisant oui d'un mouvement de la tête pour lui faire comprendre que tu l'écoute et que tu es d'accord"
Alors ça, il ya des gens des fois qu'ils font ça quand je leur parle ça m'énerve ! Tu racontes un truc un peu long parce que t'as
mal jaugé la durée de la blague par rapport à la chute, si t'explique un truc pendant 20 secondes et que la chute
est nulle, ça le fait pas. Moi, je suis un pro pour faire ça. "Ok, mec, la dernière fois je rejoins Maxence.
On va genre au monoprix, du coup. On arrive à la caisse caissière brune et tout, elle regarde Maxence et en fait c'était sa soeur
Tu veux une gifle ? Tu veux une grosse claque dans ta gueule de merde ?
Attention, si y'en a qui  le fait, j'lui mets vraiment une claque, devant tous les autres abonnés. Bon, je vous rappelle qu'on est toujours en train d'apprendre comment faire pour
ensuite le mettre en pratique juste après. Et retenez bien tout ça
L' attitude
"Déplace toi calmement, évite de faire des gestes brusques"
Mec, on dirait vraiment un guide genre pour les gens t'sais qui sont vraiment des putains des psychopathes quoi. Genre comme si un mec au lieu de se déplacer il faisait.
NON !
Les phrases d'approche directe
Une fille passe devant vous dans la rue, elle est très très jolie. Vous voulez lui parler. Qu'est-ce que vous dites ? "Salut, en fait quand
je t'ai vu, j'ai envie de te parler. T'as l'air super sympa"
"Ça te dérange si je marche avec toi cinq minutes ? C'est pour te draguer. Tu veux parler de quoi ?
Si je suis la fille, j'appelle la police tout du suite. Mais mec, j'ai envie de tester toutes ces techniques dans la rue pour montrer à quel point ça
ne peut pas marcher
Les amis nous avons
avalé les conseils de ces gens. Maintenant, il faut se motiver pour aller séduire. Alors, on va aller dans "Motive moi". Mais "Motive moi", en fait
c'est juste une synthèse de ce qu'on aime voir. "L'isoler" ?! C'est glauque
"Loin du groupe et de ses amis, elle ne subira plus de pression sociale et sera vraiment elle-même. Ce moment est le meilleur pour récupérer
son numéro, voir l'embrasser. Viens, je vais te montrer un truc là-bas / Suis-moi je vais te présenter un ami / Viens, va prendre l'air ça
fait longtemps que j'ai pas vu les étoiles
C'est trop
Bon. Vous savez maintenant comment séduire une fille, comment commencer à lui parler, comment l'aborder sans la déranger, comment maintenir son attention quand on
lui parle, comment prendre ses coordonnées pour la revoir, comment l'isoler en soirée pour encore plus lui casser les couilles
Il est temps de se faire évaluer !
C'est parti. Avant de commencer une session drague en journée, tu ne suis pas motivé et tu ne suis pas parler français. "Tu te sens mal à
l'aise, tu n'as pas d'énergie. Que dois-tu faire ? Je dois quand même aborder même si je me sens mal à l'aise / Je dois sortir
de chez moi pour me changer les idées / Je dois rien faire et rester chez moi il faut sortir et saluer les gens en
souriant ! On l'a vu tout à l'heure. Pour toi la façon de parler à une fille c'est : peu importe / vite avec une voix aigüe / lentement avec
une voix grave
Tu  l'a ajouté sur facebook, ton premier message sera : Cash, je lui propose direct un verre / mon premier message ?
pourquoi la femme n'écrira pas pour une fois ?
Pff "pour une fois" mais ferme-là deux minutes / soit je la joue classique en la saluant / soit je tente une blague avec les infos
récupérées sur son profil
Et oui mon ami, je suis prêt à séduire je crois bien. Attends, j'ai envie qu'il m'évalue pour "En soirée"
Est-ce que je pourrais séduire en soirée ? "Tu dois aller en soirée mais tu es nerveux. Que vas-tu faire pour te
décontracter ?  Je vais boire de l'alcool et fumer une cigarette / Je vais regarder sur internet des techniques de méditation et relaxation
C'est la bonne réponse, mec, c'est vraiment la bonne réponse. Mais 'ttend mais mec  faut être complètement stressé du cul pour en arriver là avant d'aller
en soirée quand même c'est fou. Tu as une heure à
attendre, tu ne sais pas quoi faire en attendant mais tu as trois idées : Je vais faire une sieste / Je vais réviser la séduction et le développement
personnel en général / Je vais commencer à boire un verre et fumer une clope pour mettre bien. Bah je vais réviser
Les amis, c'est officiel, nous pouvons séduire en journée et en soirée
Par contre le matin c'est mort
"Bonjour, c'est Paul. Avez-vous pensé à travailler cinq minutes de séduction aujourd'hui ? Laisse-moi
Paul, laisse-moi et laisse les fans tranquille. Les amis, c'est la fin de cette première application.
Attention, j'ai un petit bonus pour vous bien sûr, quelque chose qui va vous aider dès ce soir
"Envoyer des sms de séduction", c'est la deuxième application de Pierre. Situé dans une situation de panique et tué dans l'une des situations
présentes ici, tu vas pouvoir s'en sortir grâce à un sms déjà écrit
Bonjour, c'est Sofia. As-tu pensé à envoyer des messages aux filles qui te plaisent ? Mais laissez moi !!!
Tu as des vus sur une fille, ça fait vingt-quatre heures qu'elle t'a pas envoyé de message. Tu vas dans la catégorie 'elle ne répond
pas'. Voici une liste de sms pré-fait, par exemple : "Je prends souvent du temps pour t'écrire un message gentil et toi tu ignores mes efforts"
Bon, n'envoyez surtout pas celui-là.  " Ah génial tu parles à des mecs pour perdre ton temps ?
Pas celui-là non plus. "Elle dit qu'elle a un copain". Gros problème. "OK tant pis pour toi, salut."
Genre ça va passer. Si, ça passe c'est vraiment la fille qui a le couple le moins stable du monde. Non mais si elle a un copain, partez, fermée l'appli, partez,
appuyez sur ce jeu et jouez-y et passez  le temps. C'est fini. "La draguer
explicitement : Il est 11 heures 11 leur parfaite pour faire un voeux. Moi, je te veux. /
Ce film serait tellement mieux si tu le regardais dans mes bras". Oh quel loveeeer
"On a un problème. Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser à toi.". Tin mais Paul, mais viens-là Paul, on te fais des massages mon gars, tu nous
mets tous biens. "J'aime tes yeux mais je préfère les miens car sans eux je ne peux pas voir les tiens"
Attends parce qu'y'a quand même une catégorie
"Messages profonds" : il te faudra deux secondes pour lire que tu compte beaucoup pour moi et toute une vie pour te le prouver
Est-ce que je pourrais en savoir un peu plus sur toi ?"
Attends, c'est pas profond du tout ça. "Je suis un mec bien, je ne bois pas, je ne fume pas, je prends soin de moi.."
Excuse-nous, hein, toi qui est si parfait ! Je le déteste le mec qui a écrit ce message. OK. "Messages de bonne nuit. Je te souhaite de t'endormir dans le
coton doux de la nuit et de te réveiller dans la douceur du miel du matin
Bonne nuit. / Sache que je vais rêver de toi ce soir et ce jusqu'à demain.. et même jusqu'à la fin de ma vie." Mec, je
fais un référendum. Je propose de renommer cette appli "Canard Lord". Les amis, c'est la fin de cette vidéo. J'espère que ça vous a plu. Si c'est le cas, n'hésitez pas
pas à l'aimer comme d'habitude. La bonne nouvelle, c'est que maintenant on est tous capable de séduire des femmes ou de leur faire extrêmement
peur et de finir au commissariat je sais pas. Je pense qu'il ya des gens qui ont des facilités pour aller parler aux inconnus et
d'autres qu'en ont beaucoup moins et si ça peut aider des gens tant mieux. Mais dans mon cas, y a plein de trucs qui m'ont fait
marrer dans ce qu'il dit même s'il y a plein de choses qui sont vraies en réalité dans le comportement, avoir la gestuelle, la tenue, le
machin, le truc .. En fait, ça s'appelle de la PNL. Et je parle pas du groupe. La PNL, c'est la programmation neurolinguistique, c'est pas
marquer sur un écran, c'est faux, et c'est des modèles et des techniques destinées à faciliter la communication entre des gens et il a dit
des choses dans son appli, c'est de la PNL. Bon, Pierrot, merci au nom de tous mes abonnés, grâce à toi on sera un
as en soirée et en journée. Bravo pour tes applis puisqu'elles m'ont bien fait marrer et je pense qu'elles aideront des gens donc c'est
cool. Tu dois pécho un
maximum de femmes de 50 ans par contre sinon ça, ça peut pas marcher.
Allez, je vous dis à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo, merci d'avoir regardé et c'est parti pour séduire des femmes ce soir! ;)